THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GAINES [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
MURTADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LARA LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
AND PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KATHY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
SENATORS IF WE IF WE CAN ALL
PLEASE TAKE OUR SEATS A QUORUM
IS PRESIDENT WE WANNA OFFER YOU
A HEARTY GOOD AFTERNOON AND
HAPPY NEW YEAR WELCOME ALL OF
OUR NEW MEMBERS.
ALONG WITH A WARM WELCOME TO OUR
RETURNING SENATORS AND ON BEHALF
OF PROTEIN MACHEN'S WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
SESSION OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE ON THIS.
TRULY HISTORIC DAY WHERE
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM WAS
RECENTLY SWORN IN ALONG WITH
ELEVEN OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GAS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LEADING PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN AFTERWARDS
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TODAY.
BY SENATOR BRIAN JONES
[inaudible]
HE LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN
GOD'S PRESENCE.
GRACIOUS AND LOVING GOD.
WE GATHER AGAIN TO CONTINUE THE
LEGISLATIVE WORK OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
INSPIRE EACH SENATOR TO REMEMBER
DALY.
ALL THOSE WHO DEPEND ON JUST AND
FAIR LEGISLATION.
ALWAYS TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
THE NEEDS OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
PERSONS IN OUR SOCIETY.
HELP ALL OF US TO BE PRESENTS TO
pOF THIS MOMENT.
WE CONTINUE IN THE WORDS OF CHEN
RICHARDSON.
SHE SAYS NOW MORE THAN EVER.
LET US BE THE ONES WHO WILL NOT
TURN AWAY.
LET US BE THE ONES WHO WILL GO
FARTHER INTO THE RACK AND DEEPER
INTO THE RUBBLE.
LET US BE THE ONES WHO WILL
ENTER THE PLACES OF DEVASTATION
BEYOND BELIEF.
AND TO SPARE BEYOND OUR
IMAGINING.
AND TO THERE IN THOSE PLACES.
LET US LISTEN FOR THE SPIRITS.
BUT BROODED OVER THE FORM LIST
DARKNESS.
AND SPARE LET US LOOK AGAIN FOR
THE GODS WHO GATHERED UP THE
CHAOS AND BEGAN TO CREATE.
LET US BE THE ONES WHO WILL GIVE
OURSELVES. TO THE WORK OF
CREATING AGAIN.
AND TO THE ENDLESS BEGINNINGS OF
CREATION [inaudible]
A MAN.
I THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR OF
THIS AFTERNOON LET ME BE ONE OF
THE FIRST WISH YOU HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
AND PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND WHICH STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY FOR
YEAH FOR ALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER JONES
AND WE WELCOME YOU BACK SISTER
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA BE ADVANCING
IN OUR FILE TODAY.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE WELCOME YOU BACK WE
HAVE.
A LITTLE BIT OF BUSINESS HERE
TODAY.
AND OUR FIRST PART OF THE
BUSINESS OF TODAY IS UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
BUT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE PRO TEM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO TAKE UP SENATE
RESOLUTION NINE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO COMMITTEE OR FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
BUT YOUR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION NINE BY
SENATOR ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE
STANDING RULES OF THE CENTER FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION.
CENTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I THINK.
HE SAID IT ALL S. R. NINE
IMMENSE A STANDING RULE TWELVE
OF OUR SENATE TO ESTABLISH
SENATE COMMITTEES.
AND THE RESOLUTION DETAILS THE
STATING COMMITTEES FOR THE
SENATE FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
I CERTAINLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRO TEM
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
HEARING SEEN NINE MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
AYE.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BY BRADFORD.
HI KELLY ERROL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GAINES [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG I HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON.
BY [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
BY LARA [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
HI FOR LOCK BY MORALE
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PM [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
PORTANTINO
HI ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
HI AMBERG.
HI MY COUNTY [inaudible]
HI WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
I IS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED THANK YOU
SO MUCH MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE PROCEEDING
TO THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE THIS WILL BE THE
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS MISTER SECRETARY.
CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. 515-253-5450 FIVE
FIFTY SIX BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
RETURNING TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR SENATOR GAINES WE WISH YOU
A HEARTY CONGRATULATIONS AND A
WELCOME BACK EVEN THOUGH IT'S
FOR A SHORT TIME.
WE SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE CITY CALIFORNIA.
LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
PLEASE.
GAINES THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
LACKEY SAID SO MUCH ARE REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS.
AND OUR GREAT OPPORTUNITY JUST --
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN THE
SENATE AND THE OPTION TO SERVE --
IN THE ASSEMBLY IT'S BEEN A TIME
FRAME IT'S BEEN.
A GREAT EXPERIENCE AND I KNOW WE
HAVE MANY NEW SENATORS HERE --
SOME THAT HAVE COME BACK.
AND SERVE --
TO BEFORE BUT WHAT A PLEASURE IT
IS TO SERVE IN THE SENATE AND
NOTHING AGAINST THE THE LOWER
SENATE IS THE PLACE TO SERVE IN
MY OPINION --
THE COLLEGIALITY DOES EXIST IT
IS REAL.
AND I THINK PRO TEN ATKINS --
IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THAT AND
SHE HAS SERVED AND JUST THE OUR
GREATEST OF WAYS IN MY IN MY
MIND IN TERMS OF BEING FAIR.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE DEBATE
THAT OCCURS --
ON THE FLOOR KIND OF STAYS ON
THE FLOOR.
WE FIGHT OUR FIGHTS AND WE FIGHT
THIS FIGHT OF A LOT OF PASSION.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY --
WE CAN SHAKE HANDS --
WEEKEND --
DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS
FRIENDSHIPS AND SO --
IT'S BEEN A REAL PLEASURE IN
DOING THAT.
AND I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED WITH.
OPERATIVE MACHEN'S IN TERMS OF
WHAT SHE WANTS THE FOR HOUSING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW
CRITICAL THAT IS.
THAT IF WE CANNOT PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIANS THAN HOW DO YOU
LIVE THE AMERICAN DREAM SO --
I WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK IN
YOUR EFFORTS AND TO THIS BODY --
IN PROVIDING THAT --
IN THOSE CENTER WINNERS ALSO
WORKED VERY HARD NOT CAPACITY.
AND HE'S NOW I BELIEVE THE CHAIR
OF HOUSING LOOKING FORWARD TO
GET THINGS I DON'T KNOW IF I
SPOKE INCORRECTLY THERE OR NOT
BUT I'M SORRY.
SO -- I I'M
SURE HE'LL CONTINUE IN HIS
LEADERSHIP --
POSITION.
A AND I JUST --
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
OTHER MEMBERS IF I COULD --
SENATOR MINING --
IT WAS A PLEASURE WORKING WITH
YOU -- I
BELIEVE I'M TRYING TO THINK BACK
HOW LONG WE SERVE TOGETHER BUT
IT WAS A LONG.
PERIOD IN ALL OF MY TIME HERE IN
THE SENATE.
AND I KNOW YOU'VE MADE GREAT
STRIDES --
WHEN IT RELATES TO DIE BE THIS
AND -- SO I
APPRECIATE THOSE EFFORTS AND WAS --
WE WERE ABLE I WAS ABLE TO
SUPPORT.
YOUR BILL LAST YEAR --
WHEN IT CAME TO FAST FOOD IN A
TYPE OF BEVERAGE A CHILD WOULD
GET -- KIND
OF AS A DEFAULT MEASURE --
WHETHER THAT BE MILK OR WATER.
AND THEN LETTING A PARENT MAKE A
DECISION ON WHAT THAT BEVERAGE
THE FOR THAT PARTICULAR CHILD
THAT DIE AFTER THE JAVA SCRIPT
TYPE ONE DIABETES AND THE BRIDGE
A REAL FRONTAND CENTER.
ON THIS ISSUE ALL THAT IS.
TO OUR CHILDREN AND THAT THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THEY ARE --
LIVING HEALTHY LIVES --
IT'S BUT ALSO A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH GOVERNOR BROWN.
AT ALL THAT WE HAD MANY
DISAGREEMENTS WE WERE --
I WAS ABLE TO WORK WITH HIM AND
THIS BODY WAS ON SEVERAL FRONTS --
WITH REGARD TO SENATE BILL ONE
IN THE WATER.
BOND MEASURE AND HOW CRITICAL
THAT IS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAIN RELATED TO HOUSING --
WE HAVE A POPULATION HAS GROWN
BY 50%.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE ANY WATER
STORAGE --
THAT'S A REAL CHALLENGE SO --
MY HAT IS OFF TO THIS BODY TO
THE GOVERNOR.
AND TO SENATOR NIELSEN REALLY
HAVING THAT OFFERED UP ON THE ON
THE WATER BOND.
ISSUE AND THEN.
MAKING SURE THAT ACTUALLY TURNS
INTO A REALITY.
YES THE US SO --
THAT THAT WAS WONDERFUL ALSO --
ON PENSION REFORM WHICH
CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM THAT I
DON'T THINK IS REALLY RESOLVED --
BUT WE DID MAKE SOME INROADS
WITH THE GOVERNOR --
IN THAT ARENA AND I'M HOPEFUL
THAT -- THIS
BODY AGAIN WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT BECAUSE REAL CONCERN ABOUT
THE FISCAL --
THE CONDITION OF THE STATE
SPECIALLY IF WE RUN INTO ANOTHER
RECESSION.
OUT WHAT IS THE IMPACT KENNEDY.
AND HOW DO WE BRING PEOPLE UP.
TO ASPIRE TO MIDDLE CLASS --
AND STRUGGLE TO SURVIVE IN THE
STATE AND THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
HOW WE KEEP THEM THERE AND --
SO WE'VE GOT A DYNAMIC ECONOMY --
I JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE.
ON THE BOTTOM ARE HAVING SUPPER
TIME OPPORTUNITY TO RISE UP AND
ENJOY -- ALL
THE FRUITS THAT I HAVE IN MY
LIFE HERE SO --
THANK YOU SO MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CENTER REQUIRE
AND TO ALL OF YOU I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU --
AS A NEW OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
THEY HAVE HAD THEIR CHALLENGES
AND I WOULD JUST --
TO DISCUSSION THE FUTURE WE'VE
GOT A WHOLE NEW BOARD COMING.
FORWARD.
AND WE NEED TO FLY STRAIGHT.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY
AND WE NEED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
ACCOUNTABLE AND SO I'M HOPING
THAT'LL HAVE THAT OPTION YOU
HAVE THAT DIALOGUE WITH YOU IN
THE YEARS IN.
THE FUTURE.
AND OBVIOUSLY LISTENING TO YOU
BUT AT THE SAME TIME TRY TO
PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON HOW WE CAN
OPERATE IN THE RIGHT WAY SO.
IT WAS A PLEASURE AND HONOR AND
GOD BLESS YOU ALL AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY CENTER
GAINES CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THIS OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE GOLDEN STATE.
MEMBERS.
ON THIS SUBJECT WE LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR GLACIER.
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
THANK YOU AYE HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
YOU AND TO OF MY COLLEAGUES.
I WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF
CONTENTIOUS ISSUES --
AND THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE
HAVE BETWEEN US --
SOMETIMES --
OUR IT CAN BE CHALLENGING AND
DIFFICULT CERTAINLY IF THEY
REPRESENT --
THE OTHER PARTY --
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY AND I
KNOW THAT MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
FEEL THE SAME THAT.
IN ALL OF MY INTERACTIONS WITH
SENATOR GAINS --
HE HAS REPRESENTED HIS POINT OF
VIEW WITH THE AMAZING GRACE AND
GRACIOUSNESS --
WITH -- I'LL
HEART.
BOB POINTED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU.
A SENATOR GAINES FOR YOUR
WONDERFUL SERVICE I REALLY
ENJOYED --
WORKING WITH YOU --
AT A PARTICULAR THIS PAST YEAR --
AS A MEMBER OF THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE A VARIETY OF VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUES AND I
APPRECIATED THAT IN ALL OF MY
INTERACTIONS THAT.
I KNEW --
YOUR ISSUES AND CONCERNS CAME
FROM THE HEART CAME FROM YOUR
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE IN THAT
FIELD -- AND
I KNOW IT MADE THAT THE FINAL
PRODUCT EVEN BETTER.
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
REACHING ACROSS THE AISLE --
AND THAT'S PRESIDING OFFICER AS
AN AS A MEMBER OF THIS BODY OF
REALLY --
CONDUCT YOURSELF WITH GREAT --
INTEGRITY AND WISDOM AND GRACE
AND I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE WILL
MISS YOU WISH YOU WELL ON THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
I KNOW YOU'LL BE COMING BACK TO
TALK TO US OFTEN ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU FACE THERE.
BUT THE SENATE REALLY --
BENEFITTED ENORMOUSLY FROM HERE
LEADERSHIP IN YOUR PARTICIPATION
BY THANK YOU.
IF YOU NEED ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU CENTER GLACIER AND
CONGRADULATIONS SENATOR GAINES.
MEMBERS THIS IS GOING TO BE A
VERY SHORT SESSION UP IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER
ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT AND HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL ENABLE US TO GO VISIT
ANOTHER.
SENATOR SOON TOO WELL ACTUALLY I
THINK HE'S ALREADY RESIGNED --
SO HOPEFULLY WILL I GET TO GO
JOIN ONE OF OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES
AND WITNESS HIS BEING SWORN IN.
AS A CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER
THANK YOU ALL COULD BE AN
INCREDIBLY DYNAMIC EXCITING WEEK
BUT WE WILL.
RECONVENE --
ON THIRD THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM HURT HIM IN ALONG WITH MR
MAJORITY LEADER THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM MEMBERS HAPPY NEW YEAR
[inaudible]
I APOLOGIZE